bonjour à tous bienvenue françois bayrou
c'est heureux de vous recevoir et je
pense qu'on vous présente plus bonjour
bonjour en 2007 vous étiez un des
premiers à vous engager en faveur de
emmanuel macron après un septennat qui a
été agitée aux promesses qui n'ont pas
été toutes tenues ce que vous croyez
encore lui ben autrement je ne
soutiendrai pas
d'ailleurs
tous les français aujourd'hui ont sous
les yeux le veille le véritable critère
de l'élection présidentielle pourquoi l
it ont un président pas pour être un
joyeux chef demande pas pour être
seulement une figure de l'actualité
représenter la france à l'étranger n'ont
en élit un président de la république
pour qu'il puisse faire face
au plus grand défi et aux plus graves
risques on les lit pour qu' il puisse au
nom du pays
jouer le rôle de protection et
d'entraînement qui doit être le sien et
tous les français sous les yeux
aujourd'hui tous ceux qui sont pour lui
naturellement et ceux qui étaient contre
il découvre un que cet homme à la
dimension de la fonction qu'il a trahie
jauzion avait pas une vie juridique de
ce qu'il a fait de ce qu'il est non pas
du tout je je je pense que d'abord que
beaucoup a été fait si on si on vous
disait il ya cinq ans qu'on allait
supprimer la taxe d'habitation si on
vous disait il ya cinq ans qu'on allait
mettre la retenue à la source sur
l'impôt sur le revenu tout le monde
considérait que c'était impossible ça
c'est le bilan le page et nous
interroger sur le village empirer
le projet ne voit pas encore on a vu la
lettre mais on en parle à tout à l'heure
est ce que vous avez entendu valérie
pécresse elle a un jugement qui est
complètement le contraire de haut il
faut réparer la france dit elle le
quinquennat a appauvri la france et il a
faibli un coot époux le montre
on peut échanger des mots qui n'ont pas
de sens ça c'est possible mais il ya des
éléments qui sont chiffrées jamais
depuis 15 ans et notamment pas depuis
que
valérie pécresse était au pouvoir en
responsabilité jamais il n'y a eu autant
d'entreprises créées jamais il n'y a eu
autant d'emplois créés jamais le chômage
n'a été aussi bas depuis 15 ans et
jamais le chômage des jeunes depuis 40
ans 40 ans
jamais l'apprentissage n'a attiré autant
de jeunes 700000 cette année bon vous
voyez bien que on peut faire deux on
peut faire des des attaques partisanes
d'ailleurs on s'en prive pas ça me fait
toujours rire quand on dit qu'il ya pas
de campagne parce que le nombre d'
attaques de d'injures de mise encore
anges en cause une campagne de
nombreuses insultes ou les beaux jours
d'huile est alors oui et un autre
critiqué vous adresser directement à
l'essai chez les jeunes et delko
françois bayrou parraine marine le pen
sans doute pour qu'elle soit présente au
deuxième tôt bayrou a perdu la boussole
d'abord parlé de la guerre longuement un
mélange cc pour liquider ce type de
problème on va on va pas perdre de temps
à des comment vous avez perdu la
boussole anne hidalgo elle est à 2 %
dans les sondages
pour un d un parti politique a été un
des plus grands partis politiques
français
aucune de ses promesses n'a été entendu
par qui que ce soit et en tout cas pour
ma part j'ai choisi et je choisirai de
défendre la démocratie chaque fois qu'il
y à un risque et le risque que un
candidat ou une candidate de premier
plan ne soit pas présente dans cette
élection était pour moi un risque
inacceptable j'ai donc pris mes
responsabilités c'est à elle de trouver
sa boussole on passe
plus sérieusement l'ukraine et la guerre
sont pas arrêtés pendant la nuit le port
de barrio paul d'autres villes subissent
un blocus à dirigeants ni eau ni
électricité ni nourriture
serty un début de corridors humanitaires
qui va s'ouvrir là on l'a appris tout à
l'heure mais kiev est assiégé bientôt
affamés et bombardé ou va tendre et
jusqu'au
où s'arrête la folie de poutine mais
pourquoi la folie parce que c'était
évidemment
il est là la proie ou cela sans traîner
par un déséquilibre personnel c'est une
fois il avait vu sa fiche psychiatrie
c'est la première fois depuis
trois quarts de siècle
qu'un état
de surcroît européen
attaque un pays indépendant qui ne lui a
rien fait pas un incident de frontière
pas un coup de feu pas la moindre
anicroche ni mise en cause ça ne s'est
jamais produit dans notre histoire et
vous voyez bien de quelle folie il
s'agit alors j'ai fait poutine
poursuit un fantasme qui est un fantasme
d'intégrisme nationaliste il veut
reconstituer l'ancienne russie en
sacrifiant la liberté l'indépendance et
la démarre en plus et à la menace du
chantage atomique qui plane et pas
seulement sur l'europe est ce que les
puissances nucléaires
je dirais même pas est ce que les
puissances nucléaires occidentales sont
en train de se préparer emmanuel macron
promet des mesures concrètes pour
sécuriser les centrales nucléaires
comment à ce jeune je ne sais pas alors
qu'elles sont et dans l'ukraine va pas
entrer dans l'ukraine pour les protéger
comment on fait non mais vous voyez bien
aujourd'hui ce que ce que poutine a fait
l'année précédente il a tiré sur la plus
grande centrale nucléaire d'europe est
ce qu'on est sûr qu'il attirait ou qui
veut pas les récupérer toutes les
centrales pour en même temps couper
toute l'énergie c'était affamés les
propositions à fait possible mais il a
tiré sur des bâtiments administratifs de
ses centrales et vous voyez que tout ça
c'est un jeu pour terroriser les nations
les peuples
je crois que c'est un jeu qui ne peut
pas marcher
pour moi poutine ne sacrifie pas
seulement le peuple ukrainien et la
démocratie ukrainienne ni la démocratie
en europe mais il sacrifie son propre
peuple parce que au bout du chemin
qu'est ce qu'il y a il ya des
souffrances pour le peuple russe il ya
des d atteinte profonde à son économie à
ses exportations à son équilibre
budgétaire et monétaire
et donc la victime de poutine c'est le
peuple dans un premier temps après les
ukrainiens c'est le peuple russe et dans
un second temps je crois qu'il sera lui
même victime de sa propre dérive
l'ambassadeur de france est installé à
vif comme vous le savez etienne poncin
et ses diplomates sens moins admirable
il vient de déclarer en tout cas cette
nuit toute l'ukraine va y passer et
d'ailleurs c'est confirme ce que poutine
avait dit à emmanuel macron il va
probablement écrasé kiev et toute
l'ukraine mais ils sont par maison et en
même temps briser la résistance de la
nation et du peuple qu'est-ce qui reste
pour nous la culpabilité la compassion
non
jamais de sentiment de défaite il ya
beaucoup de gens qui voudraient nous
entraîner à des sentiments de de
résignation de fatalisme deux défaites
en quelque sorte c'est pas mon point de
vue il nous reste à l'ultime plier les
pressions vous croyez que aujourd'hui en
russie il n'y a pas des gens puissants
qu'ils commencent à s'inquiéter de la
manière dont leur président les conduit
l'achat de gaz par les américains les
allemands oui ça peut
sanctionner c'est tout à fait
envisageable c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous français avons choisi
d'être moins dépendants du gaz nous
avons choisi de produire de
l'électricité
nucléaire parce qu'elle est sans carbone
et elle nous rend indépendant et son
prix est stable dans nos coeurs françois
bayrou est ce que la disparition de
l'ukraine n'est pas la négation des
frontières de l'ordre des règles est-ce
que c'est pas la force qui va faire la
loi et est ce que montrer la faiblesse
symbolique morale réelle politique là de
l'occident donc je ne crois pas
l'occident joue une partie importante à
une seconde que le peuple ukrainien va
se laisser humilier
sans rien faire au cours du temps l'idée
que parce que on gagnerait parce que
c'est pas encore fait le l'appareil
militaire russe connaît aujourd'hui
comme vous savez beaucoup de limites
j'ai été absolument stupéfait lorsque le
président ukrainien et l'ins qui a
annoncé qu'ils avaient 6000 morts russe
d'abord j'ai cru qu'il exagérait que
c'était de la communication de guerre et
puis vous avez vu comme moi lorsque
poutine est intervenu avant-hier
après-midi à la télévision il s'est levé
et vend son peuple qu'est ce qu'elle a
dit il a commencé par présenter des
excuses aux maires des soldats qui
étaient à bord dire qui a beaucoup et il
a respecté une minute de leur faillite
il a imposé une minute de silence ce qui
veut dire qu'il y a en effet beaucoup de
morts russe est donc ce sont des
victimes de poutine est ce qu'il a déjà
perdu la guerre à moi je crois qu'il a
perdu beaucoup plus que ça je pense
qu'il a perdu sa place dans le concert
des nations et pour longtemps et à mon
avis à jamais ouais mais il ya quelques
experts américains genlisiens dans le
figaro de ce matin qui est très
intéressant et guider il faut pas trop
parler de sa chute pour pas l'énerver
d'avantagés qui fasse encore usage de
l'arme atomique et d'autre part il faut
lui trouver une porte de sens de sortie
plutôt honorable c'est à dire présenté à
son prix sa défaite comme
petite victoire mais il faut aller
jusque-là tout ça suppose que la
question est réglée et elle n'est pas
réglé le problème de l'histoire quand on
est en train de la vivre c'est que on ne
voit pas bien quelle direction elle va
prendre ce que je crois c'est que au 21e
siècle
dans les zones dans les années que nous
vivons des réseaux sociaux de la
formation continue du numérique partout
il n'est pas possible de faire croire un
peuple qu'on gagne quand on perd il
n'est pas possible de faire croire à un
peuple que c'est une guerre justifiée
alors qu'il n'y a aucune raison pas la
moindre balle pas le moindre prétexte
dont on puisse se saisir pour faire la
guerre à l'ukraine je pense qu'au bout
de ce chemin là il y a là des
considérations absolue et le mot est
vraiment très faible de poutine et au
bout du compte c'est lui qui sera
responsable devant son peuple ce qu'est
ce qui est important c'est clair on a
connu des guerres dans lesquelles les
peuples étaient derrière les dirigeants
mais dans une guerre comme celle là ça
n'est pas possible y sont peu informés
et en tout cas ils peuvent pas être seul
à y seront informés par les familles qui
ont des airs jcd et parents qui sont
morts seillière alors je reviens un
moment à la campagne on a vu hier la
première vidéo d'une série
présenté par le candidat et macro on
peut se demander comment il va être
candidat président président candidat
mais en 2017 quand vous étiez à ses
côtés il promettait la révolution est ce
que après cinq ans de crise est ce que
c'est ça va pas être la continuité sans
changement je crois que on se tromperait
en le croyant je pense que quelqu'un se
cet homme jeune parce qu'il est très
jeune on oublie toujours d'abord parce
que c'est très ont naturellement mûri et
qui la traversaient les crises y compris
dans sa sensibilité
cet homme jeune pendant cinq ans il a
mesuré un certain nombre de faiblesses
du pays et ils n'aiment et son et son
obsession
je crois qu'on peut le dire aujourd'hui
c'est précisément que les cinq ans qui
viennent servent à corriger ses
faiblesses la faiblesse en matière ses
faiblesses à lui ou les faiblesses dans
les faiblesses du pays en matière
d'éducation vous savez que on a beaucoup
essayé de faire on a essayé lundi va
être quelque part pour parler en matière
d'éducation les faiblesses du pays en
matière de production les faiblesses du
pays en matière de contrat social et les
les fractures du pays et les faiblesses
du pays en matière démocratique ne sera
pas encore dans les autoritaires que la
presse qu'on dit maintenant moi je suis
pas du tout sûr qu'il ait été
autoritaire je pense que parfois les
pavés goût non
vous le voyez je suis un citoyen qui a
un regard libre sur les sur les choses
je pense pas je pense que
il ay là il est entré en responsabilité
dans un pays dans lesquels les cadres
anciens joué un très grand rôle et
sûrement où il vend rien n'était facile
sa lettre a été jugée floue et creuse
mais naturellement c'est une une lettre
de présentation de sa candidature
comment comment il va être après est ce
qu'il y aura un vrai projet bds qui va
participer mais réellement
la campagne je dis pas qu'il va faire un
débat avec tout le monde pendant le
premier tour mais ce qui va s'engager ce
qu'on voit le voie pas seulement dans
son bureau parce qu'il ya la série qui
l'a fait là commencé à la faire dans son
bureau de l'elysée il a été filmé quatre
minutes et il était dans son bureau
voyez à quel point on peut faire des
polémiques un pardon de vous le dire
avec n'importe quoi mais ceux qui
croient qu'on peut faire une campagne
électorale sans présenter au pays une
vision alors un vrai projet chez parce
que ce que savait une vision une vie ça
fait très très il aura la vision que
j'ai fait des campagnes présidentielles
est très très longtemps que j'ai mis en
cause cette formulation une vision
partagée avec le pays la volonté que
l'on a et le but qu'on se propose
d'atteindre et évidemment les moyens
qu'on mettra en oeuvre il sera précis
engagé
candidats autant qu'il le faut et
président autant qu'il le faut parce que
c'est son devoir d'y à la guerre il se
serait de voir non mais vous voyez bien
à quel point mais ça va bien on a des
polémiques
enfantine légère
jean pierre elkabbach je dois vous
rappeler quelque chose sur vos plateaux
ya pas si longtemps les candidats de
l'opposition disais mais pourquoi est ce
qu'il assume la présidence de l'union
européenne
il aurait dû reporter après les
élections qu'est ce qu'on dirait
aujourd'hui si il avait renoncé à sa
mission de président du conseil de
l'union européenne
et s'il avait dire on se reverra après
les élections tous ont demandé ça et
vous ne trouvez pas que rien que ça
montre la légèreté de leur choix de leur
attitude de leur engagement et au fond
par contraste
là la gravité et le sérieux de celui qui
assume en tout ces jeunes servent le
sérieux 11,0 au début du 21ème siècle on
est en train de vivre une étrange et
dangereuse période en tout cas merci
d'être venu d'en avoir parlé merci de
votre présence avec louis d'avoir dit
que le deuxième septennat au quinquennat
c'est pas donnez moi encore cinq ans je
vais faire et corriger ce que j'ai pas
fait c'est c'est sûrement pas ça toute
campagne électorale
se gagne sur une idée de l'avenir qu'on
partage merci pas sur le passé pas
seulement sur les bilans et pourtant ils
sont conséquents mais sur quelque chose
qui va entraîner un peuple à la
rencontre de son plein quel enthousiasme
françois bayrou bonne journée si on peut
dire aujourd'hui merci jean pierre